hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press the
button now this dilemma is interesting
you gain the ability of mind control but
the people you control will be aware
that you took control of them and will
react to what you did to them while
under the effect so you can control
everybody but your manipulations are
laid bare for the people that are being
manipulated I mean the best comment says
that would be [ __ ] hilarious I don't
know what you plan to do with people in
their mind control but I don't think
it's gonna be so hilarious so basically
you become a supervillain in a way you
control people for your own ends no you
become like oh that guy what was that
guy the purple guy the purple man purple
man for his purple man you know purple
man from zooey deschanel x' Power Girl
what was it I can't remember what the
name of it was the guy he could control
people's minds with a virus and they
would do anything that he instructed
them to do no matter what it was and
they could not resist but they were
aware of it and that was horrible so I
don't think imma do that I think I'm
gonna pass on that one that whoa whoa
there's 66% of people that think they
could use that power responsibly I don't
think that's true you have an endless
supply of food but you have to work out
four hours into every day for the rest
of your life I mean an endless supply of
food would solve world hunger is that
not true
I would it would be better for everybody
in the entire world and heck I would
just get superduper in shape like I
would get crazy in shape all for the
benefit of the world I don't see you
lost there I'm gonna take that oh yeah I
would yeah also it doesn't say what kind
of workout you have to do it could be
working out in my mind
you have the permanently active power to
control your luck and the luck of those
around you but in order to control
whether it is bad luck or good luck in
the intensity you must be given
permission to by a man in a suit who
will withhold it to manipulate you as
easy
so I get to make everybody around me
either bad or good lucky if by the whims
of a man in a suit it doesn't say it
doesn't say a specific man in a suit it
says a man in a suit this could be any
man in a suit I could wear a suit I'm a
man I've got a suit I can check
I could I could do it I could do it I
could do that see I found you I'll press
that button I'll just get one of my
friends to tie themselves in a suit who
gives me lots of good luck right whoa
split down the middle there mmm all
right become God but everyone is an
atheist and hates you and you cannot
change their opinion or make yourself
happy I mean what does that really
matter
basically you become dr. Manhattan right
in in The Watchmen comics like dr.
Manhattan basically had the powers of a
god like he could make matter out of an
energy and like he could manipulate he
was a quantum being and basically
existed outside the realms of our
universe except that he was in it so you
become a god you you become a God with
whatever powers that are godly and you
can make whatever you want your destiny
is outside of it you can't change their
opinions they will always hate you and
you can't make them happy but you know
hey you got the powers of a god that's
not too shabby I don't know I'll prompt
that oh no people didn't do that
I kill them all all right well oh no
okay this is funny because I've actually
been reading a lot of Warhammer 40k
books and you will become a god-like
Emperor that rules over all mankind in
the year 40k but you'll have to stay on
a golden throne that requires souls to
keep you alive so for those of you don't
know the god Emperor of mankind sits
atop of golden throne because he was
betrayed by his son Horus during the
Horus heresy and the arcane mechanisms
of the Golden Throne
must keep him alive with the
daily sacrifice of a thousand cycles a
day lending their energy to the
astronomic on to power it for the
betterment of humanity and keep the
imperial web way closed for all eternity
oh you know sorry
I'll do that I'll take a bed charge cuz
who knows what the Loire is gonna spill
for me later I don't know I'll take it
I'll do it I'll do it
give me a good put me on that throne
make me a God actually that probably
terrible kind
I can't imagine just sitting in the same
chair for 40,000 years might as well do
Let's Plays while I'm up there I suppose
a fridge that contains any food drink
you want fully prepared and ready to eat
whenever you open the door but the
fridge takes up half of the space where
you live you still have to pay for the
food and you still gain weight well
that's well that's fine by me if I could
have cracker-barrel chicken and
dumplings anytime I want and they are
too expensive I'll puff by that that's
awesome and half of the space where I
live well I mean that's fine I don't
need that much space by food anytime I
want I could have people over and I can
impress them with any delicacies that
they could desire that sounds great I
want that
give me that fruit what crazy people
I guess that mean you could just cook it
Tammy Armour so in normal fridge you
just don't have to cook damn it you're
right god damn it god damn it you're
right you become the doctor's new
companion and travel through space and
time but you will die during an
adventure
so I'd become his new companion and that
and then I generally just be what his
companion is and then I would die for
the Doctor Who am I going no cuz that
never seems to turn out well no matter
which way you slice it no matter what
happens
like you'll create an alternate version
of yourself that will have to suffer or
you'll be the alternate version of
yourself and then you'll die in a time
loop and basically going with the doctor
is just a horrible horrible horrible
thing I will not do that sir not do
you have the abilities of changing into
any creature you want Animorphs but you
have to stay that animal for a month
every time you change appearance I mean
okay can we go mythical animals what
kind of creatures are we talking about
here can I be an alien can I be anything
gonna be different versions of people I
mean technically humans are an animal I
can just change my face every month and
stay incognito for the rest of my life
it doesn't sound so bad I'll do that
I'll do that
hell yeah everything will be free just
for you but except for electronic goods
which will be more expensive I think
this guy's got the right idea about it
Sebastien exchanged diamonds and golds
and other raw materials for cash I mean
technically yeah that's kind of working
around the system this doesn't say that
exchange don't exist I can get something
for free and then sell it later and get
anything I want yeah that sounds good
there's no downside to that easy-peasy
oh no live in the world of gta5 but it
is in 8-bit why would I want to do that
because luck be habit for me I wouldn't
be one of the main protagonists or
antagonists in that game you know the
type that gets to go to the hospital
every time no I'd be one of the regular
street people that has people in rocket
ships just exploding over the horizon
every single morning and they just
respawn when the police
Carine and through my house and then I
die instantly and even worse my life is
an 8-bit how is that any better I don't
want that at all no thank you I don't
want any part of that let's say you can
end all suffering in the world all
oppression and essentially create world
peace and save billions of lives but you
must choose you must chose one of the
people you're closest to in the world to
act as a sacrifice I mean one one life
for the end of all suffering like I
don't even need to debate this one I
don't you know I know I'm sacrificing
one of my friends here but hey I think
that one of my friends would be like oh
yeah that's that that's a good deal
sacrifice me I can guarantee you that I
would have a friend and if I
friend of mine needed me to sacrifice
for that outcome oh yeah oh hell yeah oh
oh sacrifice me up burn me on a pyre I
don't care okay are you cowards you
cowards you can control a mind but it's
only your mind so what are you saying
like I have the amount of control that I
would have over like a sim I'll assign
myself to a task and I won't be able to
change it because my mind wants my mind
to do that how does that work for my
mind control my mind you don't know what
my mind does my mind is my mind in my
mind alone but but if my mind is
controlling my mind does that mean
there's my mind or my mind telling my
mind what to do I don't mind if my mind
tells me what to do because of my mind
I'll brush oh no oh my brain hurts
alright you can see through clothes and
see anyone naked I don't know if I want
that but everyone around you everyone
around can see you naked when you use
the power hey no downside everyone gets
the glory of me naked God why would I
want that
why would I want to be TSA oh I don't
think I want that I don't want I don't
want I don't want to see everyone naked
I'd rather not you know I will not do
that
oh really fifty-one percent of people
are so desperate to see everyone else in
the world naked God you don't know what
you're asking for there ah oh no I mean
I know it's optional I know it's
optional you don't have to do it all the
time and there's use for it here and
there but I mean it's like I don't need
that I don't need that I'm good my life
is okay without that I'm good
ooh this is interesting you can create a
universe exactly as you've detail it but
in order to create this alternate
universe you must die so basically
you're creating a universe that you
would never ever be a part of you it's
not like you die to go into this
universe you can create a world that you
want with your rules exactly the way
that you wanted
you'll never enjoy it so in the end is
there really a point to it is the
creation of this world that is basically
fiction to you but is real to the people
in it and will really tangibly exist is
that worth dying for and how would you
even have all of the wherewithal to be
able to detail every small nuance about
that universe we don't even know this
universe and we got like a billion
people working on that idea so how would
you be able to detail every absolute
detail it would be a lifetime endeavor
just being able to create this universe
but would it be worth it if it was made
in the first place and would it be worth
it it could cost you your life think of
any fictional universe that you've ever
wanted to be a part of you could make
that a reality and maybe hope that
you'll be born into it after you die but
there's no guarantee for that so let me
know down in the comments what you would
do would you create that University
would cost you your life let me know
down there so thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you enjoy this
one let me know if you did down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]